right my name is Eric Jonas I'm
currently a postdoc at UC Berkeley in
EECS working primarily with been wrecked
partly as part of the new Berkeley
Center for computational imaging and
partly as part of this new thing called
the rise lab which is the evolutionary
spiritual successor to what was
previously known as the amp lab and
today I'm going to be mostly talking
about a little bit about my my actual
day job but mostly about this this
platform that that we've started taking
advantage of offered by Amazon Web
Services called lambda and a a software
layer we wrote called pyrin that's
primarily designed to make a lot of the
data science type calculations that we
do easy and what do I mean when I talk
about those types of calculations and I
want to say you know it really I'm a
little bit older than I think the
average postdoc and it does really in
many ways feel like the wheel is has
come around again and even again and in
particular a lot of things that used to
be very easy or at least I remember them
as being very easy now I may have been
22 at the time so who really knows seems
like they've gotten very hard and so
we're gonna talk about how we can kind
of perhaps reverse that trend a little
bit forward for the both the users and
the classes of applications I care about
and and what are some of those examples
well a lot of what we do
oh and going back this is of course all
joint work with with my colleagues
Shivaram chiffon and then our advisors
Ben and yon the I am NOT a systems
person by I'm much more in the applied
math bucket I'm so this has been a fun
adventure I think for everyone involved
but a lot of what we work on our
problems that are of a computational
imaging nature so problems like adaptive
optics where you'd like to kind of in
real time adjust parameters of your
imaging system to see things better or
super resolution microscopy where you
want to use kind of strong priors about
your image to see things you couldn't
see before or to problems of tomography
where you'd like to see inside some
structure just from boundary value
measurements or problems like phase
contrast microscopy
we're the actual image that you're
trying to receive recover is not visible
in your target wavelength but if you can
exploit properties of phase delay then
maybe you can see the the target and in
all of these application areas we have
this amazing property where we often
have very good forward models right
physics especially at this scale is kind
of by and large worked out and so what
we end up with are very good forward
models that would like to run many many
many times and often these are forward
models that are being run using existing
legacy pieces of software and perhaps
rewriting them all is not a good idea
for certainly not for a postdoc maybe
not for a graduate student and so part
of our challenge was how do we convince
some of these colleagues though that
we're collaborating within these
computational imaging spaces to give up
their loved tools right so a lot of
these busy physicists and double e's are
all real matlab affection autos ryan and
as someone with kind of formal computer
science training the idea of writing
matlab as part of my day job makes me
want to vomit a little bit similarly how
can you convince how can I convince like
some my solar physics colleagues to give
up tools like IDL right which is kind of
like MATLAB but worse in every way and
it's hard because there's a tremendous
amount of legacy software that's been
written and in both of these pipelines
and and and so the question becomes kind
of how do you convince people what is
the hook you can use to get them to
transition over to something that looks
more modern or is is kind of more
amenable to say contemporary machine
learning techniques like Python and so
that this was kind of the other hook
here was can we build a platform that
offers kind of sufficient advantage that
we can we can use this as a hook here
but of course I hate computers exactly
exactly
no and and and and there's this real
problem knowing that like you know the
reality is that that we all reluctantly
use these these approximations to Turing
machines on our desk because they can do
lots of powerful things but also you
know as someone who actually spilled
coffee on my laptop keyboard two nights
ago and the shift key is not recovered
since the physical instantiation of the
hardware is an incredible pain point and
then
so simply configuring and working with
them can be quite a challenge and this
isn't this isn't just something that
those of us who aren't real systems
people run into I mean we have this
weekly computational imaging lunch and
one of our graduate students some of my
collaborator Shivaram was trying to
explain to everyone when they should be
using cloud infrastructure because you
know on one hand as my PI been likes to
say cloud is just another word for
someone else's computer and that's true
but there are a lot of potential
advantages including reproducibility and
and scale and the inability or the the
fact that you don't personally have to
be the person making large capital
outlays that make a lot of these novel
cloud computing environments attractive
but what while we were giving this talk
in Shoreham was walking through kind of
you know what the different storage
mechanisms are and the difference
between s3 and DynamoDB and all of these
sorts of things one of the PI's Ren Inge
who's now professor at Berkeley said
well why is there no cloud button and at
the time we all thought he was nuts and
we're like that's such a Ren thing to
say like of course you want to think
about like the simple product that we
could try and sell it's very a product
focused P I and what would a cloud
button even be but when we started
talking about it and talking to more and
more of our colleagues we came to this
realization that in fact there is no
cloud button but maybe there could be
and and in fact it really does seem that
the cloud is too damn hard for a large
class of users so so Jamison quill on
the the founder of the the rent is too
damn high party may have really hit on
something here right and when we did a
survey in the amp in the event and Platt
now rise lab of graduate students so
these are graduate students for with P
is like Yan Stoica Mike Jordan you know
these are these are the people who
should be using parallel distributed
programming primitives that we're
building in-house and less than half of
the graduate students in our group had
ever written a spark or Hadoop job and
this wasn't necessarily because they you
know they had all taken the I don't
where the Berkeley Oakland it is of the
theoretical to should be computing class
that was taught by like Nancy Lynch at
MIT when when I was an undergrad like
everyone understands these primitives
but it's just hard there's a lot of
friction and even though we kept running
into situations if you're like god I
wish I could scale this operation out to
a
10,000 nodes relatively quickly no one
was doing it and part of that reason is
that you know when you start trying to
use infrastructure like Amazon Web
Services right so this is ec2 instances
dot info and it's the kind of easy view
of all of the different types of
machines so all the different
configurations that Amazon will let you
use and you know it's not really that
easy of a list parse right and of course
I know what all these things mean now
and many of our graduate students do but
it's very bewildering for someone just
coming to this ecosystem right and so we
started joking about how the cloud is
too damn hard and you do have to start
making a lot of these decisions even
before you start using this
infrastructure right like what instance
type are you going to use what is your
base image you want boo bun - do you
want some sensuous derivative and if you
start saying these things - like when
you're applied physics friends they're
gonna say like why are you asking me
these questions I just I just want to
run my code and then on top of that when
you start thinking about kind of trying
to scale up your job for many of these
types of em structures including spark
you have to make a lot of commitments at
the beginning how many instances are you
spinning up how much you want to be
spending on them do you want to be using
things like spot instances which are
ephemeral but potentially cheaper and
you have to make all these decisions one
after another after another and that and
then you're left with a naked machine
which is kind of a bismal and you have
to start doing things like configuring
it with spark receipt or using any of
the kind of well curated yet still
somewhat fragile pieces of
infrastructure and so what we really
wanted was something that people could
use for their embarrassingly parallel
jobs which had very little overhead for
setup right the hope is that once
someone had in Amazon Web Services
account and I'm gonna mostly be focusing
on AWS partly because they're kind of
pioneers in this space and partly
because we have most funding from them
so it's easy to accidentally spend a lot
of money once someone has one of these
accounts it would be great if they could
just start using it right we don't want
there to be some sort of persistent
overhead we don't want someone to have
to keep up a larger expensive cluster
nor necessarily wait for a 10 minute
classic wait 10 - 20 to 50 minutes for
one of these clusters to come up and I
know that that might not sound like a
lot of time but it really ends up being
this insane piece of research friction
to the point where even those of us who
are comfortable with the tools like I'm
gonna spin up a cluster I don't really
want to like it's it's a lot of friction
so we want this low overhead for setup
right and we'd like to have low kind of
developer overhead for users as possible
right now now in some sense if you're
the sort of person who has been writing
Python code for doing your data analysis
right so you're not a systems person but
we're these kind of vaulted data
scientists that everyone keeps talking
about it would be great if you could use
a system like this through a reasonable
interface right and ideally support as
much of your legacy code as possible for
lots of people you know we've written
our serial pipelines we have some
function and we really just now want to
run 10,000 copies that what would say
different parameter settings right but
we've got maybe you know 5,000 10,000
lines that have written for this paper I
don't want to have to rejigger that into
some fundamentally different computing
paradigm just start using it so we'd
like to support as much of your kind of
existing work as possible we're
targeting jobs that run in kind of the
minutes or more regime I think that's
also important right in any distributed
systems as I'm sure you all know there
are all these trade offs and and the
kind of transaction overhead that you
might pay for making something simple or
easy to use would potentially hinder
your ability to run a bunch of say tiny
tasks right so so we are we're in
general when people are using PI random
like think about jobs and granularity of
30 seconds or more right additionally
here I don't really want to run a
service right that is I don't want to
offer a front-end for other people to
use I don't personally want to be the
person maintaining some server or some
batch queuing system or whatever I would
like to directly pay AWS and that that
that fits into because you can imagine
you could have certainly built something
somewhat like this at any point over the
past say 10 years where you're taking in
people's jobs you're running them and
you're spitting out the results but I
don't want to be doing that I think most
people don't want to be doing that
either this brings to our next point
that like whatever we're using has to be
from a cloud player that's likely to get
an academic grant you know Amazon Google
sure
there certainly are startups in this
space and there have been for the past
few years they've been trying to tackle
either this problem or similar problems
but generally they're not excited to
give 100k of credits to an academic
project right I am
and there is also the question of how
long are they going to be around so the
hope is that we can kind of take
advantage of large established player
technologies so to go through this again
we want minimal overhead right we'd like
the target kind of vanilla Python users
for jobs that run in kind of the minutes
to more regime we really don't want to
be the people running some particular
service so we don't want to do our own
startup and we'd like to actually not
depend on additional kind of players in
the ecosystem outside those who we kind
of trust in our gonna give grants so
what are the type who are the humans
that we're writing this for because we
are these theoretically writing this for
humans it's basically ourselves and our
friends right which is not surprising so
I want a parameter do pipe a parameter
sweeps over some filter of parameters
for looking at every image from the Sun
or one of my computational imaging cloud
looking colleagues Nikola Antipa he has
a 10-minute algorithm he runs for image
recovery and now he wants to do video so
he took you know a thousand frames and
he'd like to be able to just do this
without having to wait forever or Kevin
Jameson are a group who works on active
learning he has a nips paper that's due
in six hours this is with you know I
think 27 days before the nips deadline
this is increasingly true and you want
air bars for that figure and why is it
that I'm gonna have to wait you know and
times the job for my job running to do
something that looks like a simple Monte
Carlo search so maybe the reality here
is not that I hate computers but I hate
servers right I love the idea of
computation I hate the fact that there
exists these physical entities that I
have to manage I have to make all these
decisions about behind the scenes I have
to personally worry when they die and so
we started building this piece of
software called PI render right so you
know you can have a silhouette of a
condor in the background some of us have
actually played with with condors as a
job scheduling system and what we really
wanted was the small version of that
right so most wrens are small and rather
inconspicuous birds except they have
loud in complex songs and so the hope
was that we could kind of target these
sorts of Condor rescues cases right but
in a way that preserved a lot of the
elasticity that people have come to
expect from the cloud and two pieces of
technology kind of fell in our lap right
one is this Python distribution from a
company called continuum
called anaconda and the other is this
service from Amazon Web Services called
lambda right and so I'll start with
lambda so lambda is really neat because
what lambda basically does is lets you
execute arbitrary functions on Amazon
servers on the cloud where there are
some interesting constraints here right
you get 300 seconds per job of a single
core right AVX to Eric or you get 512
Meg's in temp you get one-and-a-half
gigs of ram and they'll give you let you
run Python Java or node code an Amazon's
goal for this has been very much one of
building distributed systems for kind of
companies building distributed systems
using this kind of idea of micro
services where maybe you have one
service that takes in images into six
them an s3 you have another one that
maybe then you want to grab the images
from s3 do some processing on them and
stick the results in a database and
you'd like to have that kind of
dynamically scale with your customer
load and more and more people are trying
to build these sorts of services using
these sorts of fast running functions
right and you know they're Amazon's
model does very much seem to be people
building these sorts of things that
scale of kind of the number of users and
Amazon's not the only one providing
these things cool has their cloud
functions which actually I think just
entered beta and Microsoft has there's
your functions which which are similar
so they provided this platform for us to
kind of quickly and efficiently run
these serve these functions on the cloud
so we'd like to provide an interface
which looks like this right we'd like to
just be able to have some arbitrary
function in this case you know add one
which is not doing anything terribly
exciting directly get a handle to an
executor and then just map our function
over some list right the primary
interface here that we're giving people
is simple it's a simply a functional one
right because these functions themselves
are stateless all right this is the kind
of the neat and weird point in this
ecosystem but of course you can then you
get a list of futures back it actually
maps to the Python futures interface
very closely and the output is expected
this is not terribly exciting right but
the scale that you're potentially
capable of achieving with this interface
is kind of we found it surprising right
so if you look on the on your left there
right we have we see that kind of the
aggregate compute for doing D gem on
each of these right so doing dense
matrix matrix multiply here
unsurprisingly scales linearly with the
number of these these workers that are
running right the number of these things
that you're kicking off behind the
scenes but the important point here is
that you're not telling Amazon I want
2,000 or 3,000 or 5,000 workers you're
saying hey look please give me as many
as you possibly can here's my
embarrassingly parallel set of jobs
please run them and you see that you
know on average this is with using em
Kaela's are backing numerix we get kind
of for each of these cores we get about
16 gigaflops of matrix vector multiply
the other neat things here include you
there's this little bump here at 32
because of course when they tell you you
get a core you get a hyper threaded core
so it's a fake core so on some of the
jobs they actually get a full core to
themselves and and they're running at
twice as fast mix benchmarking a real
fun exercise the other surprising thing
is that of course so you have these
stateless functions but you say oh my
gosh Eric I have lots of state right I'm
taking in data I want to save the output
how do i how do I handle that well we're
out all of this through s3 Amazon's
object store and okay that's fine but
you know isn't that slow and it's
certainly the case that you know writing
to s3 you can write it about 30
megabytes a second and reading from s3
is on average about 40 megabytes per
second and that's what that histogram is
up there and there's some variance there
but the amazing thing is the total
aggregate throughput from these
simultaneous workers that you can get to
s3 approaches you know 80 gigabytes per
second for write or for read and 60
gigabytes per second for write and that
really surprised us right what that
suggests is that you know on the back
end there Amazon has kind of this
incredibly scalable piece of
infrastructure and that's starting to
change the way we even on the system
side think about building these sorts of
distributed systems that do more than
even simply offering this kind of map
like or MapReduce style interface and I
hope I can convince you that there's a
lot you can do with map including kind
of a large number of ETL type compute
right so you want to extract some
features from a bucket of images or
whatever as well as these sorts of
parameter tuning cases and whenever I
talk to my my distributed systems or
friends or people who are building kind
of large-scale machine learning systems
like well those cases are all boring and
in some sense they're right right like
pre-processing all of imagenet computing
some deterministic features and then
throwing that into some large-scale
learner is kind of boring but it's so
hard with the existing infrastructure if
you don't already have something set up
right and so for this example here where
we say hey look we have all image net
would like to run some basically random
Python code for feature ization
including now we have people who are
using you know early stages or continets
for this thing we'd like to kind of run
this as quickly as possible how can we
do that and so pyrin makes that sort of
task easy and I can show you kind of the
the job lifetime here where the the
x-axis here is the the run time and wall
seconds right so we go from 0 to 250
seconds for processing all of imagenet
here where the blue dots that you can
kind of barely see on the left here or
when the jobs are actually submitted
from your workstation right
unsurprisingly then the jobs get started
these are these green dots here right so
that's when Amazon actually pulls them
out of its queue and begins running them
right there's some jobs set up here
which all which is this gap here I'll
talk about in a bit the jobs run and we
retrieve the results unsurprisingly for
example there are stragglers because
both there's variance in terms of trying
to get data in and out of s3 and
sometimes for reasons we don't even
quite understand terribly well there's
contention on the individual nodes I
mean these things are all heavily
containerized and who really knows
what's going on behind the 9 layers of
virtualization there but we can look at
the histogram of the amount of time that
each of these phases is taking right and
kind of unsurprisingly that are
surprisingly to me actually the starting
latency for when your host throws
something over to lambda2 when it starts
executing it is shockingly low right
kind of on the order of the mean is
certainly a second and the the max
there's roughly let's say 3 or 4 seconds
but then there's this the set up time
can be up to 20 seconds and again I'll
talk about that in a minute
and then you do the compute that in this
case it's about 120
Berthe compute and fetch the results
what's happening behind the scenes and
again I really want to stress that this
is not this is not rocket science
although my aero-astro friends are
always telling me that what they do is
also not rocket science so it's not
clear what that means but this is not
this is something an undergrad could put
together and indeed the original version
of this was all written in a weekend all
we're really doing here so if you if the
left side is your laptop the right side
is the cloud right is when you execute
one of these map invocations right from
the runner of the executor all we're
really doing is we're serializing your
function in your data right we're
sticking it on to s3 right we're
sticking it into amazon's a binary
object store we invoke one of these
lambdas so lambda as an interface
basically is designed such that you
upload a function then they want you to
invoke that many times so we've built
kind of a shim handler here right so
that we always invoke it the same way
but some of the parameters we pass it
tell it which of these functions today
to execute on and then remotely what
happens is in that lambda they pull the
job from s3 they download those two
objects right it downloads a Python
anaconda run time that we've prepackaged
right it actually then begins invoking
Python out of process to run your code
right meanwhile you're back here in your
laptop you've you've invoked the results
right so it's now going to block waiting
for that result right and the begins
polling s3 again like my actual systems
friends are like you're polling the
object store what the hell is wrong with
you but it totally works and it's super
reliable which is great
eventually that function will return we
pick up the result right we serialize
the result using Python pickle we stick
it back in s3 we get the result return
it to you and from your perspective it
basically just looked like a map right
now to make this happen there's a couple
of things we depend upon and I don't
actually have good slides for it here
but the unsung hero here of I think a
lot of this is the underlying
serialization technology right so
generally one of the the big challenges
and trying to get your code to run
someplace else is handling dependencies
and handling the fact that there's a
tremendous amount of State so the
dynamism of Python makes kind of a head
of time compilation and ginning and all
those sorts of things really challenging
but it does mean that there's actually
kind of a nice in-memory
that can be very easy to walk and figure
out what those dependencies are so we
actually you depend on a package called
cloud pickle which is maintained by the
PI SPARC team to pick a little closure
it's a serialize closures and kind of
all of the Associated ecosystem and
state and then we also do some module
dependency analysis such that if you
have pure Python modules on your own
machine that don't exist remotely will
quite happily upload them and make those
work as well right but then we also have
this anaconda runtime right so this is
this is the world's tiniest snake right
it is not a Python and we would like to
have a very small version of a runtime
that pre includes all of these Python
packages right and this is somewhat hard
because again remember we only have 512
megabytes of storage on the actual
machine that these functions are running
on so we have to somehow get an anaconda
Python install which is roughly twelve
hundred megabytes to fit into that space
so we start doing kind of increasingly
stupid things right so we first run the
conduct healing command which gets rid
of a bunch of the the build system derp
the the install system detritus we
eliminate all of the package related
metadata which gets us down to nine here
forty six Meg's we manually delete all
the non avx2 shared objects from mkl
right so that actually saves us a fair
amount that gets us down to 670 we strip
everything out of the shared libraries
that we don't really need including all
the debug symbols
godspeed that gets us down to five ten
and then if we delete all the
intermediate python cache compilation
output right we can get down to 441
megabytes right so we can kind of barely
sneak ourselves in under that 512 limit
to let us run again kind of the full
Python or side eight a sweet
behind-the-scenes right then we're
downloading this run time we run tarring
it and that's where that 20 seconds of
sutta of occasional set-up time comes in
and then invoking our function now so
unfortunately behind the scenes amazon
with lambda is caching a lot of this
right so in fact that lambdas are
running inside containers and these
containers are not purged for every
function invocation this originally
caused a lot of confusion when you'd run
one lambda form
and then you'd run another one and you'd
look in slash temp and there was crap
there and you're like well where did
where did that come from
eventually we realized that it was our
own stuff and in fact these and incited
an individual container it would be
reused for running various lambda
functions so we use that to cache these
run times when we download them so the
first time we do it it takes that 20
seconds but all subsequent invocations
that take place inside that container
are much faster and don't incur this
overhead it's actually kind of neat to
start trying to then reverse engineer
what lambdas doing behind the scenes and
particular trying to do things like host
identification so of course these are
containers running inside like Xen VM is
on machines somewhere and like Oregon
and so one thing we found for it that's
fairly reliable is that the MAC address
for the container of course stays the
same
I guess not of course it stays the same
for the the lifecycle of that container
as far as we can tell right and we've
done things like you know using various
measurements of pinging hosts and
whatnot to try and make sure that's the
case so for the the next little bit when
I talk about individual hosts right or
individual containers that are running
these lambda jobs I'm doing the
identification based upon MAC address
it's not perfect there's potentially a
lot of problems with that but for the
time being I think for what I'm trying
to show it it's it's fairly viable so
what you see then here on the right
right is the is the time between job
invocations in seconds right and the
color of the dot there right a black dot
means that when we invoke that job the
runtime is already present and a white
means that the runtime was not present
we had to redownload it right and then
the host ID this is from like 0 to 150
here are the unique MAC addresses sorted
and kind of the order of which we saw
them first from one of these results as
we just kind of sequentially invoke a
hundred jobs so we invoke a hundred jobs
we wait like 50 seconds we invoke
another hundred jobs we wait fifty
seconds just to get a handle on what the
caching behavior of these things looks
like and unsurprisingly you know
initially we have some cached up here
left over from the previous run but you
can see these white ones here right
these are all new hosts
that we start talking to that we haven't
taught that we haven't seen before
and then for reasons we don't really
understand the next time we do an
invocation some of those hosts are gone
right and some new ones get kind of
birthed into existence right so we start
seeing some new things and of course
over the invocation of doing this ten
times we end up seeing about 200 unique
hosts and then of course we can titrate
what that delay looks like right and
what you see down here then is on a log
scale but what really I think is useful
is looking at the time between job and
vocation here and again this is in Lagos
and one two five ten thirty minutes and
so on versus the fraction of new hosts
that we've seen and so we see is that
kind of after 30 minutes or so all of
these instances have been kind of shut
down restarted and we're getting a
hundred percent new hosts so behind the
scenes Amazon is spinning up these
containers letting them linger for a bit
and then killing them at what looks like
roughly somewhere between 30 minutes and
an hour and you can start then looking
well what happened so right now I've
been showing where numbers where we have
maybe three thousand of these
simultaneous workers what happens when
you ask it to do say 10,000 jobs worth
of activities right or in this case we
know that we have roughly 2,000
simultaneous workers and we're going to
invoke many more than that jobs and so
what you see here is if this is the job
ID here you can see that these jobs are
all kind of sequentially started and
then when we do it again because there's
variance and when the jobs completes you
start getting this kind of jumble from
when the job itself actually starts but
the order is kind of roughly preserved
here that said there are real
ramifications for trying to build
distributed systems on top of lambda and
in fact one of my my friend colleague
and former graduate school roommate for
five years
Keith Wynn Steen is a Stanford professor
here and he's the person who I had been
playing with lammed and he's like well
if you're just email Amazon I'll give
you 3,000 and they'll let you run up to
3,000 jobs simultaneous that's like it's
great so he's actually working very
intensely on trying to build kind of
real scale distributed systems on top of
lambda whereas I'm much more interested
in kind of taking advantage of this
computing fabric for again the sorts of
applications where we really just want
it easy as heck map now you can start
talking to other Amazon
services including s/3 s/3 is
interesting because if you imagine if
you try and execute a single transaction
where you write something to s3 and then
read it back immediately where you're
just writing a single 16 byte object
right so you're writing two doubles and
reading them back how many of those
transactions can you get per second
right in the actual number of those
transactions across a large number of
lambda 0 so we scale up to 200 we don't
actually above that you know we can see
we're kind of thresholding out here you
can only get roughly let's say four to
five thousand simultaneous transactions
per second to s3 so when you start
thinking about trying to back-end other
sorts of distributed computing
infrastructure out of this or say use s3
as a synchronization layer that ends up
being potentially a challenge and what
you get is these nice errors from s3
where they're like please reduce your
request rate just kind of you know it's
nice to have Amazon telling you that
you're trying too hard but what we end
up having even before we hit these
limits is it easy to use map and that
means for a lot of kind of data science
workloads we're happy but often map is
not enough right a lot of data analytics
and a lot of the data analytics that we
do ends up you have some data where
evidently the cool figure for data
always looks like some nebulous thing
from from a CNN ad from 1999 you do some
ETL or some pre-processing on it which
is generally embarrassingly parallel and
then you do some feature ization which
is again embarrassingly parallel right
and then you throw it into some machine
learning algorithm where that's shown by
a bunch of boxes connected to other
boxes these sorts of features asian
steps write all this embarrassingly
parallel stuff is actually a great pyrin
fit right it's everywhere that Hadoop
has had some sort of success right but
on this far state over here especially
at scale there's this idea that you need
some sort of distributed scale
tensorflow deep ml based something
something right you need you know this
is a hard problem and doing this at
scale is a hard problem and so that
means that we're not going to be giving
Jeff Bezos money here and that that
makes Jeff Pizzo sad but we think we can
actually you know maybe that's not
necessary and and you know frankly
sherry and a widely celebrated paper had
this great quote from Pat Barnum which
is you can have a second computer when
you've shown you know how to use the
first one and Frank Witcher has all
these great figures are these cables in
his paper scale
at what cost that he had it at Hutto s
two years ago where he showed that
actually kind of using the right data
structure he could get performance on
his laptop right and a single-threaded
implementation that exceeded a lot of
what you could do with these large-scale
distributed computing frameworks now two
people are building to serve a framework
computing frameworks were like well yes
obviously that's the case there's a lot
of overhead involved in trying to scale
these aren't necessarily the right scale
but in order to remember that for most
of us were not actually at kind of
Google scale yet right and and many of
us won't be many of us just have this
problem where they're in this weird
interstitial position between our laptop
can do and what we'd like to do in the
cloud and so we built in support for
kind of scalable single machine reduce
right so why not just have a big server
right with a lot of RAM and try and do
all your machine learning on that thing
you say but I don't have a big server
but again that's where Jeff Bezos can
help right so Amazon now gives you the
the ability to rent by the hour these
kind of insanely powerful workstations
right with large numbers of GPUs or
large numbers of CPUs and insane amounts
of RAM right the X 1 the X 1 dot 32 X
large has 2 terabytes of RAM and 64 like
real cores and you can rent it for $14
an hour so for comparison we bought a
machine with that number of cores but
half of that Ram 1 terabyte Ram it was
like 55 k so the real substantial
capital investment so the idea that you
know especially if you're right trying
to do something like fit do you use
random features to fit a large SVM or
something on one of these machines you
can get access to this kind of RAM and
this kind of compute for only a couple
bucks means that building an interface
like this where we do our large-scale
distributed map over our data with
lambda and then we do the reduction all
on a single large machine is very
possible and of course because this is
all happening in Amazon's bubble the
data transfers are incredibly quick and
so we've been using this sort of
framework for what up until what was
machine learning up until let's say 2013
right or 2014 so everything before you
start talking about deep learning
actually tends to fit pretty well in
this framework obviously not everything
I really want to stress that we're we're
making I think no
we're trying to make no contentious
claims here right the reality is that in
fact most of what our colleagues work
with fits into this sort of framework
and being able to take advantage of a
machine like this again for 14 bucks an
hour or so for 30 or 40 bucks total
depending on your compute is really
advantageous right but you can also
start trying to do crazier things right
so we can spin up via Amazon's elastic
cash reticences and start trying to do
things like use Redis as a parameter
server right and you can imagine that
having your lambdas kind of swap
information and do coordinated
optimization through those so we're
using plate recently playing around with
using Chiron coupled with Redis for
large scale kind of derivative free
optimization for various problems that
end up looking like reinforcement
learning and it works kind of again
shockingly well the nice thing is you
can just take your existing legacy C
library or existing Python and ship it
out there right you might say well but
for these sorts of systems I don't I
can't use Amazon's infrastructure right
this doesn't really help me I already
have you know a cluster but fortunately
you know companies like kubernetes are
doing an impressive job of taking this
kind of container orchestration
technology and providing function like
interfaces on top of it right so there's
this hope that kind of maybe this idea
of not malla conservers to run your jobs
that actually malikan kind of tiny
little bits of computation via functions
might be a path forward even even
locally and so for us and one of the
things dennis asked me to talk about is
what we're what my actual day job is
we're using it for a lot of what we
think of as interesting applications
even if the underlying kind of
computation graphs are not terribly
interesting right we do a lot of
computational imaging so so my group and
with Ben works closely with Laura
Wohlers group to build imaging systems
that exploit computation to let you kind
of get away with with with novel or
crazy ideas on the hardware so you can
imagine for example trying to build a
camera where you instead throw away all
of the existing optics infrastructure
right no lenses but basically take a
piece of diffuser so shower privacy
glass right the stuff that's in your
shower window hopefully
and just basically randomizes the
incoming direction of light and so if
you imagine if you if you take that you
place it you know let's say 200 300
microns in front of your CCD you take an
image you get something that kind of
looks like this right which looks like
junk but of course most the information
is still there you can do a lot of
pre-processing and actually recover the
image and what you've really built here
algorithmically is a camera system that
exploits the underlying physical
properties that the diffuser coupled
with a lot of kind of compute including
exploiting these complex forward models
and running large scale solvers to solve
this and and and everyone you know most
of the people who are working on this
it's not actually us right it's very
smart kind of applied physicists who
again are kind of potentially trapped in
this MATLAB hell and we were able to
convince them well try rewriting your
forward models in Python or porting some
of your existing legacy code and see
what you can get and now they're capable
of kind of doing scale doing these sorts
of problems for right now there were
previously they were just at the single
stage camera phase or single stage image
phase and now they're doing video so
they're they're the people we're trying
to empower here similarly you know I
work with with some colleagues here at
Stanford on various interesting problems
and solar physics including kind of
trying to understand what gives rise to
various explosions on the surface of the
Sun so what you're looking at right now
is a picture of the Sun and various
wavelengths captured by the NASA Solar
Dynamics Observatory which generates
about one and a half terabytes a day of
solar imaging data and that interesting
region there that seems to be doing
stuff is called an active region and
sometimes for reasons that we don't
actually quite understand these very
energetic active regions explode and
just send large streaming either large
bursts of x-rays or large streaming
chunks of plasma towards the earth and
we'd like to be able to understand what
that happens and and potentially even
predict it so what we've been doing is
is using again the solar data from SDO
through lamda to try and do this sort of
analysis but there's a tremendous amount
of pre-processing that has to happen to
each of those images before we just
start trying to run some sort of
classification or regression algorithm
on them and so we've ported all of that
we've been using all of that with lamda
similarly we do a lot of computational
neuroscience right so neuroscience we're
increasingly generating these insane
data volumes right what you see on the
left there is the connectome of a mouse
right now so it's literally the the
schematic diagram of the connection
between a thousand different neurons in
the visuals in the early stage of the
system so in the retina which actually
does a tremendous amount of analog
computation of a mouse and the
connectivity matrix there is is the the
squared labeled a and we've been
building kind of probabilistic
algorithms with kind of strong
nonparametric priors to extract out with
those with the circuit diagrams look
like and what the underlying cell type
and cell morphology is right and all of
that is basically large-scale Markov
chain Monte Carlo which is anyone who's
done MCMC knows you'd like to run a very
large number of simultaneous chains to
get a good estimate of your posterior so
we've been using lambda there for kind
of scaling up these sorts of MCMC type
tasks and we're even talking with people
who are interested in probabilistic
programming approaches about backing a
using PI R and as a back-end for their
computations because again they have
large numbers of independent operations
that they wish to run simultaneously
we've even been you know playing around
with what the limits might actually be
of neuroscience right so we wrote this
paper somewhat for fun where we took a
classic system the moss 6502 right we
reverse engineered it or some people we
were we know of did we have a simulator
that's capable of playing Donkey Kong
and then we took all of that resulting
data from that brain and applied
neuroscience data analytic methods to
try and understand what was actually
going on and for surprising the summon
surprising the others actually from
purely observational data of high
dimensional time series it's difficult
to say definitively without strong
models about what's going on in the
computation and this suggests that maybe
you know there may be some challenges
for Neuroscience and this big data
universe lying ahead but for all of this
we were able to use PI R n to both run
the forward simulations to do all the
per image analysis and kind of push
everything forward right and if you're
at all interested in kind of what is the
neuroscience of a microprocessor look
like I'm also speaking on this tomorrow
and fill philosophy and symbolic systems
class because you know who doesn't want
to come down to Stanford twice in one
week
so we're trying to get to the point
where we have large numbers of people
and of using this system and teasing out
where the challenges are right so we've
been ready phone's been running some
experiments where we see that you know
lambda will scale up to a point but then
we're starting to hit with some of those
limits are and so we're very curious
kind of how can we get around some of
those limits including doing things like
aggressively spinning up discrete Amazon
instances behind the scenes that the
users aren't responsible for right now
we do a lot of munching of the control
and data pipe plane because it was
written by some dude in a weekend and so
we're trying to segregate that out to
potentially kind of allow for more finer
grained control over when jobs fail or
break or when things are getting retried
and then the real the real star of this
in some sense is the serialization
technology that of course we had very
little to do with and a lot of that
credit goes first to the PI SPARC team
and then before that to a startup called
multi vac which was trying to offer a
similar service and there I mean there
are just a lot of weird weird edge cases
in Python right the Python sub-process
module that you you know you call to
invoke some at a process thing when it
throws an exception that exception is
actually not pickable for no good reason
other than there's a bug and that bug
has persisted for like years because why
would you be trying to pickle the profit
why would you be trying to serialize the
processes the exceptions thrown by this
random sub process thing so there are
lots of these sorts of things that were
having a special case and kind of make
that technology more more complicated
but we're hoping to kind of isolate that
out into a separate project so other
people including a new distributed
systems project that at Berkeley called
ray as well as a machine learning
project called clipper can use but other
than that the again this is this is only
due to my colleagues that we've gotten
this far but the code is available and
you can pip install it if you have an
AWS account you can play with it and
break it and let me know if you run into
any bugs other than that any questions
[Applause]
yes sir
with the MCMC case we're talking about
earlier how like there's a burning
period right and that kick and that
can't be parallelized
right like you should get visual
subclass testing do that I guess how do
you know when you've reached the end
great so in fact the the the burn is
that burnin is in many ways the thing
were most trying to like paralyzed right
or run large numbers of chains to get
around right for the the question of
when you hit the when you're MC MC chain
is burned in is an open one that no one
has a good answer to right for us what
we actually do in practice is we start
you know 10,000 chains from different
random initializations
we run them for a long for a long enough
time such that for compared to what
we've seen on synthetic data they've
mixed well enough that we get the right
answer right but there's there's no I
mean this is I used to be a real MC MC
diehard and now working in a convex
analysis lab I may have backed off a
little bit for my belief in the
probabilistic religion but it's hard
it's hard but the nice thing is again
for for our belief especially for these
kind of structured nonparametric models
the thought is that 1 anytime you're
there's lots of symmetries present in
that resulting posterior because like
you know there are lots of equivalent
cost strings that have different
assignments right so these kind of these
label switching problem type things and
so starting from a bunch of different
RAM random initializations is the only
thing we've really found it gives us
enough of an accurate kind of estimate
of the posterior where we kind of
believe the uncertainty coming out of it
on the other side but in each of those
cases you know we eat the burn in for
the first you know 5 or 10 or 15 or 20
minutes and then then take a couple of
samples and then call it good other
things people have looked at in the MCMC
space include techniques like parallel
tempering that help you get around this
and you know those sorts of things are
also kind of super amenable to these
sorts of lambda jobs where you run a
number of chains and then you kind of do
this you know it's a standard BSP type
work flow right we're going to change
synchronizer no bunch of chains
synchronized and lambdas a nice fit
so that is your question oh great
other questions yes sir so you you
download all of the dependencies so
still there yes coherent state no you
could go and muck about with them if you
wanted but yeah we the s3 objects all
have are all like hashed for you right
they'll have some ie I D which reflects
the which is just this hash of the
contents so we identify our runtimes
based upon those and then we download
them if the URL that we're using as our
runtime is that particularly ideas
changed like slash temp do you provide
any sort of soso right so as far as
we've been able to tell so Amazon
provides no I mean these are we're
getting increasingly in the area of
things that Amazon doesn't really make
claims about in public right so from
what we've seen either temp is there and
exists in the state that you left it or
you're on a completely new machine right
and so what we do by caching we don't we
do no no no integrity checks at all
right so if Amazon had some Dame in the
winter and randomly deleted a bunch of
crap then would just be it would be a
little bit screwed right but we haven't
seen that in practice we find that the
if if a lambda has some detritus in it
than it is both our detritus and has not
been mucked in any sort of substantial
way does answer your question
so they're massive well so that you
don't ever share a lambda with a
different account and in fact you don't
ever share a lambda with a different the
as far as we can tell the tuple of your
Amazon username and the lambda function
are always given unique containers so if
I upload two different handlers those
two handlers will never see each other's
temp at all and we've we've gotten some
kind of verbal confirmation from
randomly running into AWS people that
that's the design of course you know the
containers are not I mean part of that
the concern here is in fact that the
containers actually aren't terribly
secure right and in fact when you when
you run these things and you start
poking around you're like oh I can see
other processes here and I can see like
you know there's other weird information
leaking out from adjacent jobs but as
far as we as far as we know all of the
containers even on one virtualized host
are only unique to that username lambda
function tuple right but I'm I'm
guessing there exists enterprising
security people who are working hard to
confirm or deny those statements but
that's what we've seen otherwise I mean
that actually is one of the challenges
and trying to scale something like this
up even internally inside an
organization right is that you know I'm
not sure how much I would want other
people's code that I didn't necessarily
trust running in an adjacent container
on one of these things or kind of one
after another yes sir it's exhausting oh
I never I don't think I've ever actually
asked for system entropy it's a good
question the everything I do is with a
you know MP 1997 a pseudo-random source
I do nothing interesting
cryptographically or anything like that
so I don't actually know that's a that's
a be a neat thing to check I actually
have no idea how how even you know hard
when droopy works with containers at all
right maybe just return zero zero zero
all the time I assume not that it might
any other questions awesome
thank you
you